pontificat pour jean paul ii forte
progression des chèques sans provision
les banquiers sont inquiètes
voilà monsieur bonsoir comme si la
misère et les calamités naturelles ne
leur suffisait pas les tchadiens se sont
engagés dans une guerre civile sans
merci dont il faut rechercher l'origine
sans doute plus à l'extérieur qu'à
l'intérieur du pays d'ans djamena la
capitale les combattants des différents
clans sont désormais seul face à face le
dernier contingent de soldats congolais
de la force neutre africaine à quitter
la ville les forces françaises se sont
regroupés elle pour ne pas être mêlé au
combat et poursuivre une aide et une
assistance médicale très importante en
raison du nombre de blessés et de morts
qui augmente chaque jour la population
elle fuit le pays en traversant le
fleuve chari pour se réfugier au
cameroun
c'est toute cette situation tragique
conséquences d'un conflit très difficile
à cerner par sa complexité que tente
d'expliquer nos envoyés spéciaux patrick
clément et jacques douai qui ont réussi
à faire parvenir ce reportage ils sont
plus de 60 min ce soit en tuiles
réfugiés tchadiens qui ont fui djamena
ces combats arriver là depuis plusieurs
jours ils se sont installés comme ils le
pouvaient ils manquent de tout mais
surtout d'eau potable
pour les blessés obligé de fuir
l'hôpital de jam et neil catastrophe
la traversée fut une épopée s'ils sont
encore en vie c'est grâce à un médecin
suisse construit un hôpital
j'ai pensé je peux amener mes malades
ici les fournir à vie les médicaments
jusque ça marche
si ça pète à l'autre côté ils ont déjà
là donc ici nous somme que tech a mené à
quelques mètres du feu rachad à quelques
centaines de mètres des ménages se
trouve l'autre côté ici donc les
français viennent d'installer un hôpital
ils peuvent opérer entre 15 et 20
personnes par jour tous des combattants
disent est navré qui sont acheminés par
la croix-rouge à travers le feu tchad le
djamena haïssent
malgré le matériel on se disposent
certains blessés attendent des soins
depuis plusieurs jours dans des
conditions d'hygiène déplorables
malgré le matériel dont ils disposent
les chirurgiens français sont souvent
obligés d'employer des moyens extrêmes
surtout des amputations pour fuir
djamena est arrivé en face au cameroun
les tchadiens par milliers traverse le
fleuve aguets en pirogue la capitale
tchadienne étant coupée en deux
par une ligne de feu infranchissable
nous sommes donc obligés de prendre le
même chemin
en temps normal il suffirait de 15
minutes pour aller d'un quartier à un
autre
aujourd'hui à cause de ce grand détour
pirogue
il faut plus de trois heures
hissène habré contrôlent la plus grande
partie de la capitale
petit habitants osent y reste in seuls
circulent quelques véhicules de
guérilleros ce au milieu de ce faux
calme et de ce silence
un couple de français a refusé de partir
nous avons mais pour moi tant de tous
les côtés et nous sommes là je ne va pas
nous ne sommes pas prisonnier attention
mais enfin nous sommes là bien autant
chez une insurrection
mais dans cette situation pourquoi vous
êtes resté je suis resté parce que comme
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure si j'étais
et nos tortues que je m'amuse en sur
d'autres étapes je serais parti avec
mais là je suis obligé de rester parce
que tout ce que je possède est ici et
j'ai travaillé dur pour avoir ça et je
me vois mal partir maintenant tout
abandonner je n'ai pas le courage de
faire à quelques centaines de mètres des
entrepôts de monsieur mode l'un des pc
lycée d'un vrai ils en changent
constamment sa mobilité sa science du
secret lui ont permis jusqu'à ce jour
d'éviter les obus de ses ennemis ses
lieutenants les armes à la main sont
affairés sur un tapis autour d'un énorme
transistors c'est l'heure du bulletin de
radio france internationale alors que
l'un d'eux se prépare pour la prière on
nous reproche l'inexactitude des
informations données
et puis on se défend ici d'être profond
c'est tout en nous faisant remarquer que
la france devrait soutenir plus
activement hissène habré position
paradoxale
ce ne sera pas la dernière
création militaire hissène habré refuse
de nous recevoir mais à l'africaine
après plusieurs heures de palabres enfin
le voici le ravisseur de madame claude
les cheveux ont blanchi le fief rebelle
toubous a vieilli pas l'interview mais
une brève déclaration
elles se livrent un combat entre deux
hommes envers les forces nationalistes
qui défendent des caps dans son
intégrité territoriale et dans son unité
et l'espace rétrograde des apatrides des
alliés de la vie
délégués par l'inpi nous n'arriverons
pas savoir si oui ou non
hissène habré veulent des paraîtront
française ces guerriers en tout cas qui
contrôle aussi la totalité l'efs
d'afrique n obéissent aux ordres aux
ordres d'hissène habré qui règne ici en
maître absolu
on peut véritablement vérifier son
pouvoir lorsqu'on nous montre des
prisonniers dans ce pays la tradition
exige l'exécution sommaire
il faut vraiment que le grand chef soit
craint pour que cette vingtaine d'hommes
et sauver leur vie
du côté de goukouni on sent un manque de
cohésion
le relâchement dans la discipline le
pouvoir à moins monolithique que chi
senna bré au milieu de ces deux forces
ennemies qui partent combattants
interposés sont tendues depuis quinze
jours les troupes françaises elle se
réclame une stricte neutralité
la conférence franco africaine de paris
il n'a pas pu éviter d'aborder le
problème du tchad ne serait ce que parce
que les réfugiés de ce pays vont venir
s'ajouter aux 4 millions existant déjà
sur ce continent et qui sont un
véritable problème économique pour
l'afrique
le ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur jean françois poncet a répondu
aux questions de bernard rapp sur
l'attitude de la france dans ce conflit
convient d'évoquer la france comme vous
le savez poursuit au tchad depuis
bientôt deux ans d efforts ininterrompus
pour promouvoir une solution pacifique
une solution de réconciliation
soyez assuré qu'elle continuera ses
efforts malgré et en raison même des
difficultés auxquelles nous assistons
toutes sortes d'efforts et de tentatives
sont en cours la france pourra-t-elle
rester neutre en toute hypothèse
écoutez la france et les forces
françaises sont neutres et je crois que
tout le monde l'observent et tout le
monde le reconnaît
et je crois qu'il faut qu'elle le reste
tous les chrétiens du monde commémore
aujourd'hui la mort du christ à
jérusalem des milliers de pèlerins ont
remonté la via dolorosa celle du chemin
de croix de jésus christ cette année les
différents calendriers léturgie
coïncident et toutes les églises
chrétiennes célèbreront ensemble les
fêtes de pâques avant une siège de
l'église catholique romaine le pape
donnera dimanche sa traditionnelle
bénédiction de paepe de pâques par dont
jean paul ii dont le dernier acte
politique en bac aura été de recevoir le
roi hassan ii du maroc qu'il a confié
qu'il était favorable un statut spécial
de jérusalem garantissant la liberté de
culte pour toutes les religions pour qui
cette ville est un lieu sacré les prises
de position politiques de jean paul ii
ses voyages à travers le monde ne font
pas l'unanimité certains même dans
l'église catholique comtesse tout
apprécié cette activité débordante dupas
rome victor vraiment
un pape qui soulève les enfants il faut
être grand et fort ce n'est pas évident
pour un pape jean paul ii m la foule est
là le sens des contacts physiques avec
la foule
peu à peu cette image de jean paul ii
s'impose au monde entier ce qu'on sait
moins c'est que depuis son élection
jean paul ii a maigri 10 kg diagnostic
activité débordante il reçoit énormément
il écoute il s'informe
il dévore des tonnes de journaux mais
ils mangent peu on a voyagé toute la
nuit pour voir le pape
tout me plaît en lui tous en tant
qu'homme en tant qu pas lorsqu'arrive le
printemps les audiences publiques du
mercredi se déroule place saint pierre
la salle d audience à l'intérieur du
vatican est devenu trop petit depuis que
c'est jean paul ii qui a que les fidèles
il est debout dans une chip pour que
tout le monde puisse le voir au vatican
en murmures vedettariat
cela dérange jean paul ii est le premier
pape qui avoue oui je suis heureux
d'être pape
c'est un type sympa c'est un type bien
il est humain consécration nouveaux
cardinaux jean paul ii est le premier
pape qui réunit régulièrement des
conseils de cardinaux des sorts de
conseil des ministres il écoute et il
décide en prenant son temps
quelle prudence de la part de jean paul
ii qui a nommé secrétaire d'état c'est à
dire premier ministre le cardinal
casaroli serviteur habile effacé deux
pôles 6 pendant des années pas de
changements imprévus pourquoi il vous
plaît at-il pape il va voir les malades
les gens pauvres
il voyage
comment situer ce pape qui attire les
foules le pape polak comme on l'appelle
en italie a évoqué l' église du silence
dans les pays de l'est mais sans jamais
condamner communisme pas de durcissement
attendu
physiquement il donne l'impression de
vouloir aller de l'avant mais il n'a pas
cédé un millimètre de doctrine
catholique sur le caractère sacré du
mariage l'avortement la contraception ou
le célibat des prêtres c'est au point
qu'on a prétendu qu'il voulait rétablir
le port de la soutane et la messe en
latin
ce qui est faux l'énigme de jean paul ii
six énigmes il ya c'est sans doute tout
simplement que nous n'arrivons pas
encore à nous habituer à ce qu'un pape
forcément gardien de la doctrine soit
aussi un homme plein de vitalité
physique et intellectuelle et à vous il
vous plaît le pape fin de la crise
gouvernementale en italie de nouveau
gouvernement présidé par monsieur
cossiga démocrate ça tient compte neuf
ministres appartenant au parti
socialiste qui revient au pouvoir après
six années d'absence
une fois de plus les communistes n'ont
pas pu entrer dans ce gouvernement
politique économique rigoureuse et lutte
contre le terrorisme reste l'objectif
prioritaire de ce nouveau cabinet sce de
président de la république monsieur ping
qui a largement contribué à dénouer
cette crise gouvernementale en iran la
sphère des otages américains de téhéran
après les nombreux échanges de ces
derniers jours le gouvernement américain
s'est enfermé curieusement aujourd'hui
dans un silence assez menaçants dit on à
washington la presse américaine spécule
même déjà sur de nouvelles sanctions
économiques et diplomatiques possibles
contre l'iran de la part du gouvernement
américain
washington qui semblait conciliant afin
d'améliorer le sort des otages reprend
donc sa totale liberté d'action c'est ce
que l'on semble penser pour l'instant à
washington les chèques en bois
fleurissent en france autrement dit les
chèques sans provisions sont en forte
augmentation 22 % l'année dernière
contre 10 % habituellement c'est ce
qu'indique le très officiel et sérieux
rapport de la banque de france
cette augmentation plus que rapide n'est
pas sans rapport non plus avec la
situation économique comme nous le
montre cette enquête
jean-claude run en france un chèque est
signé toutes les secondes et sur 3
milliards de chèques émis en 79 1
millions était sans provision
les chèques sans provision ne constitue
pas pour nous un véritable problème dans
la mesure où en règle générale nous
réussissons à obtenir le règlement des
personnes qui possèdent une identité
bancaire ce qui pour nous est un facteur
de préoccupation sont les chèques volés
qui pour l'exercice passé se sont
élevées à environ 500 mille francs soit
à peu près 0 5 pour mille de notre
chiffre d'affaires
la délinquance augmente c'est vrai mais
il ya aussi l'encadrement du crédit plus
sévères et peut-être une anticipation
trop généreuses des rentrées de fin de
mois cause directe ou simple coïncidence
le nombre des chèques en bois a commencé
à croître en juillet dernier date de la
hausse de 1% des cotisations sociales
en tout cas devant le phénomène certains
commerçants ont affûté leurs armes nous
avons au printemps constaté une certaine
diminution du nombre et du montant des
chèques sans provision reçu en 79
pourquoi parce que nous avons mis en
place une série de mesures
les unes dissuasive c'est à dire
photographie au moment de l'émission du
chèque de l'émetteur de la pièce
d'identité et du shaq est mis d'autre
part nous avons systématiser les
poursuites contre les émetteurs de
chèques sans provision quelle que soit
la somme en cause le chèque reste
toutefois un moyen de paiement assez
sûre il n'y à bray tout qu'un incident
pour 3000 chèque
c'est officiel les problèmes problème en
perspective pour les élèves et leurs
parents
les 24 et 25 avril prochains les
enseignants appartenant aux gaines cfdt
au syndicat national des instituteurs et
professeurs de collège sont appelés à la
grève pour protester contre les
fermetures de classes et pour réclamer
de nouveaux crédits pour le budget de
l'éducation la fen participent au
mouvement par des arrêts de travail de
travail pardon aux mêmes dates les
compagnies pétrolières réclame d'une
augmentation de 8 centimes du super afin
de répercuter la hausse du cours du
dollar qui sert à régler les factures du
pétrole mais
le ministre de l'industrie monsieur
giraud a dit qu'il fallait attendre pour
voir si cette hausse se confirmait avant
de décider quoi que ce soit par ailleurs
le nigeria et l'iran déjà augmente le
prix de leur pétrole c'est peut-être le
signe d'une nouvelle escalade des prix
du pétrole
hier soir nous vous l'annoncions déjà
l'explosion d'un pétrolier de plus de
100 mille tonnes au large de la tanzanie
provoquant la mort de six marins mais
heureusement le pétrolier naviguait à
vide il n'y a donc pas de pollution act
presque en même temps un autre pétrolier
de 100 mille tonnes également sombré au
large du sénégal pas de victimes points
communs troublant peut-on dire entre les
deux accidents
les deux navires battait pavillon
libérien c'est-à-dire pavillon de
complaisance réédition heureusement
beaucoup moins grave de l'accident
ferroviaire de toronto au canada dans la
banlieue de boston cette fois ci aux
états unis un train transportant des
wagons citernes contenant plus de 5000
litres de gaz toxique de chlorure de
phosphore a déraillé 2000 personnes ont
été évacuées
80 d'entre elles ont dû être
hospitalisées toutefois le gaz s'est
rapidement dissipée et ne présente pour
l'instant plus aucun danger
six morts dans l'incendide un
établissement psychiatrique de blois une
dizaine de pensionnaires ont été
blessées ce serait l'un des malades qui
aurait provoqué le sinistre en tentant
de se suicider cette clinique est
dirigée par une jeune équipe de médecins
à piquants les nouvelles thérapeutiques
qui laisse une certaine liberté
waouh patients avec les conséquences
éventuelles que cela peut avoir
gérard d'allemagne hier soir dans ce
château transformée en clinique
psychothérapique près de blois les 50
pensionnaires sont dorment parfois grâce
à des somnifères et des tranquillisants
qui peut être freineront les réactions
face au drame 21h01 affirme y aperçoit
un lit en flammes et c'est celui d'une
malade qui a déjà tenté plusieurs fois
de se donner la mort pas un seul défaut
dans le système de sécurité pourtant
quelques minutes plus tard le bâtiment
est embrasée six morts asphyxiés six
blessés brûlés ou intoxiqués
aucun malade n'était enfermer ni
attaches y raconte un sauveteur quant à
la direction de la clinique elle précise
que la camisole n'est plus en usage
depuis bien longtemps dans cette maison
utilisant il est vrai les dernières
techniques d'ailleurs écouter un
spécialiste
il s'agissait d'une clinique qui était
formée d'une équipe médicale très
centrée sur les techniques
relationnelles que l'on appelle en
france le courant de psychothérapie
institutionnelle qui met en avant un
certain type de rappeurs et des changes
entre soignants et soignés entre les
pensionnaires entre eux qui est le
support mène de la qualité des soins et
de la poursuite de la cure où chacun
d'eux est évident ceci implique la
disparition de toutes les deux les
procédés archaïque que l'on a connue au
siècle dernier au début du siècle mais
que en échange de quoi la qualité des
soins s'en trouve extrêmement accrue
alors on peut s'étonner tout de même de
ce manque de sécurité pendant la nuit
il est certain que dans les conditions
actuelles les soins sont surtout
centrées sur les échanges ou des
installeurs sur les relations qui
s'établissent entre des gens qui vivent
là dans ce milieu se cognant ce donc
pour cela être armé aussi bien niveau
théorique que pratique n'est disposé
surtout d'un personnel suffisant il faut
dire qu'actuellement les réductions
budgétaires des établissements publics
comme privés que nous imposent les
difficultés financières de sécurité
sociale sont de nature à ne pas
faciliter ce contrôle et cette vigilance
politique le maire socialiste de brest
vient de démissionner à la suite du
refus des conseillers communistes de sa
municipalité de voter le budget une
nouvelle élection doit avoir lieu après
demain c'est une nouvelle illustration
peut-on dire des difficultés des
municipalités de gauche en france
polémique à propos de la présence de
monsieur georges marchais à paris ou à
moscou en 1955 l'humanité et la cgt ont
présenté une photo montrant monsieur
georges marchais à la tribune d'une
réunion de la cgt en 1955 à paris
le journal le matin a affirmé
aujourd'hui que cette photo n'a pas été
prise en 1955 mais en 1953 l'humanité
affirme que c'est une simple erreur de
transmission on en est là mais il y aura
sûrement des suites encore et puis
justement jours au sujet de cette
affaire
georges marchais
de manière l'express qui avait lancé la
sphère publie un sondage réalisé par
l'institut louis harris 50% des
personnes interrogées pensent que cette
affaire affaibli le pcf 30 % estimant
que la position du parti communiste et
renforcer ou sans changement enfin 61%
des personnes interrogées pensent que
monsieur georges marchais ne doit
accepter une commission d' enquête sur
son passé que si cette commission
examine celui des autres grands
dirigeants actuels politique en france
suite de l' affaire des otages de
bastelica en corse en janvier dernier le
commandant pierre bertolini qui avait
été enlevé et gardé en otage par les
autonomistes corses vient d'être inculpé
pour association de malfaiteurs il était
déjà en prison depuis le 13 janvier
dernier sur place en corse une dizaine
d'attentats à l'explosif ont été commis
la nuit dernière à bastia notamment
contre divers établissements commerciaux
sport maintenant tennis résumé ce soir
des quarts de finale du tournoi de monte
carlo avec au filet gilles cohen jean
françois caujolle ici au fond du court
n'a même pas fait illusion cet après
midi à monte-carlo contre le
tchécoslovaque tomas smit
il a été battu 6 2 6 0 après sa victoire
contre le numéro trois mondial jimmy
connors
on espérait du français une confirmation
de ce bon résultat
on s'était dit que caujolle était
peut-être le second attendu depuis
longtemps pour épauler yannick noah en
coupe davis
l'espoir s'est vite écroulé jean
françois caujolle l'est sans doute mais
on le savait déjà qu'un joueur moyen au
niveau international sa défaite contre
smid ne fait que le confirmer
mais le choc de la journée c'était le
match entre l'argentin guillermo vilas
anciens vainqueurs en 1977 des
internationaux de france et l'américain
john mcenroe deuxième joueur mondial
ce fut une partie somptueuse avec une
bille à ce sommet de sa forme et à
mcenroe ici très bagarreur
vraiment
village finalement l'a emporté 6 1 6 4
mais on a bien cru au deuxième set que
mcenroe pouvait reprendre l'avantagé
grâce notamment à son fantastique jeu à
la volée demain les demi-finales et
seront borg à cheyrou light is heavy la
caf tomassi
impressionnant départ du rallye
automobile de liste african safari
une épreuve toujours spectaculaires dans
les parent a été donnée à nairobi aux
quilles au kenya 3 étapes 5500 km de
pistes une dure épreuve pour les pilotes
les moteurs aussi la carrosserie
également j'espère que pour votre départ
en vacances de pâques si vous partez ce
sera moins mouvementée que sur ces
images que vous voyez actuellement
c'est un record vieux de 75 ans auquel
s'attaque trois équipages français qui
vont tenter de battre le record
justement de la traversée de
l'atlantique dans le sens etats unis
france les explications toujours de
l'inusable gilles cozanet voici
atlantique le bien nommé ce trois-mâts
goélette détient en effet depuis le 29
mai 1905 le record de la traversée de
l'atlantique entre new york et le cap
lizard à la pointe sud ouest de
l'angleterre
douze jours 4 heures une minute et 19
secondes
voilà le temps que vont essayer
d'améliorer gène riguidel sur le
trimaran qui lui a permis de remporter
la transat en double et thierry maschera
sur le grand monocoque de 21 m cardio
france
une performance que jeune riguidel
estime à sa portée si le mauvais temps
et avec lui la de lentilles nord au mois
de mars et il ya de la brise
vous pensez que c'est la bonne époque
pour faire la tentative de record mais
je pense qu'il vaut mieux prendre le
risque d'avoir trop de vent que pas
assez donc mars
et c'est le cas je crois que c'est la
bonne époque est ce que c'est ce que
votre bateau est adapté à ce genre
d'épreuve
sabato qui va vite et je crois que pour
pour le battre le record il faut un
bateau vraiment rapide
il faut faire des noeuds de moyenne pour
une très longue période donc
tous les bateaux rapides sont adaptés
malheureusement le mois de mars 1980 a
été clément sur l'atlantique riguidel a
dû attendre le mauvais temps pour
appareiller de new york
les conditions météorologiques sont en
effet essentiel dans ce genre de
tentatives il suffit d'une seule journée
de calme et toutes les chances de
réussite disparaissent eric tabarly qui
n'est pas un chaud partisan des records
en temps réel n'a pas tout à fait tort
quand il prétend que ce sont des
loteries
il suffit aussi d'une tempête trop
violente qui causent des dommages
irrémédiables au bateau et quand il
s'agit d'un trimaran les risques davari
sont a priori plus important est fait
pour éviter c'est à dire qu'il est il
est très très léger et mon mari la paix
non de parts et légèreté il manque un
petit peu d'activité sauf pour certains
parlent notamment au niveau du vraiment
on a quelques prime serait de contrôle
de man parce qu'à pas tellement on est
sur un support qui n'est pas aussi
rigide qu'on le souhaiterait en les
mines et le gréement joue un petit peu
là comme boucher automatiquement ça se
répercute serait tenue du mort
les trimarans n'ont pas eu de chance
l'année dernière sur ce même parcours
celui de michael burch a dû se mettre en
fuite devant la tempête
celui de olivier de kersauson et est
désintégré dans un coup de vent violent
et celui de alain clickz man a été
retourné par une vague alors souhaitons
meilleures chances eugène riguidel
car s'il ne réussit pas ce record de
l'atlantique pourrait devenir le record
maudit la météo pour terminer je pense
que ça intéresse pas mal le monde ce
soit en raison des fêtes de pâques
demain donc le temps sera frais le matin
avec des gelées au sol n'épargnant que
les régions côtières le ciel dans
l'ouest sera peu nuageux après la
dissipation des brumes matinales les
nuages seront un peu plus nombreux dans
l'est avec quelques ondées de pluie ou
de neige en montagne
les vents seront généralement modéré
sauf en provence et dans le languedoc où
ils seront assez forts et si je me
souviens bien hier laurent broomhead
nous a promis du soleil également
pour dimanche nous demanderons des
comptes la semaine prochaine si ça n'est
pas vrai ce soir dernier journal avec
pire alain demain samedi ennemis
l'émission présentée par jean claude
mongeau qui vous expliquera comment se
maintenir en forme avec des spécialistes
de la condition physique des médecins
des diététiciens et même des experts en
rajeunissement je pense que ça intéresse
pas mal de monde
voilà à